hello everyone and a special welcome
back to all of our salty tomb raiding
fast and furiosa e viewers out there
today on the show it's a fantastic femme
fatale fracas has two of the biggest box
office badasses on the planet goteta in
a contest from which only one will
emerge unscathed nah they'll both be
fine it's just for fun here but i your
host mark ellis take this show seriously
and i'm prepared for a battle that could
go down to the bitter end between
angelina jolie one of the stars of the
new mcu film eternals and charlize
theron a great actress whose name i
think i'm pronouncing properly in one
corner you have the original big screen
lara croft who can brag about being a
high octane assassin an evil entity
whose horns make her 10 feet tall and a
mom who can't find her kid in the other
corner it's the newest monster in that
fnf franchise who also kicks
post-apocalyptic ass has shaken the hand
of the devil and was in the 1997 comedy
hit trial and error
really that's on the resume
still
and while neither star replied to my
many social media please to appear on
the show in person today we have a bunch
of stats and clips and clips that i'm
sure they'll enjoy as they excitedly
watch from home
or a private jet or a yacht outer space
rich people do a lot of fun stuff these
days here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic characters round four greatest
hits
and then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve who's won more oscars
oh right they only have one each okay
how about who's been nominated for
multiple razzies and i've been told they
both have okay but in no world are both
angelina and charles involved in the
united nations
get out they both are well good for them
they can do it all beat up bad guys
torture good guys and possibly bring
about world peace
[Music]
one is gonna win today's reindeer game
and the other will be gone in 60 seconds
or however long this fit ends up being
let's get it on
first
you do this radical thing to your hair
stop i think it's fine i think it's fine
but i also think it's traumatic
round one box office
since they came on the scene in the mid
to late 1990s both angelina jolie and
charlize theron have dominated the box
office landscape starring in a wide
variety of roles with one thing in
common us audience folk we want to go
see whatever kind of movie they make on
the biggest screen possible combined
they've done over 70 films that have
generated over 11 billion dollars
worldwide but if you've ever seen this
show you know that we don't allow team
ups gladiators get to your corners
charlize theron scored the first big hit
for either competitor today when her
supporting role in 1997's the devil's
advocate helped keanu and al pacino rake
in a total of 153 million dollars across
the globe two years later angie can i
call her angie do we have intel on that
countered when 1999's the bone collector
collected over 100 million bucks or
bones they've been throwing haymakers
ever since combining for 14 films that
have cleared the 300 million dollar
international mark but again we don't do
team ups on verses all told charlize
theron's total box office receipts add
up to 5.6 billion dollars which divided
by her 40 films makes for a sparkling
fresh average of 137 million dollars per
picture those numbers have recently
enjoyed a b12 shot thanks to her
involvement as a straight up psychopath
in the fast and furious films the fate
of the furious is the only movie for
either star that has crossed the one
billion dollar mark earning a total of
1.2 billion that best angelina jolie's
highest earner maleficent by almost 500
million dollars but whereas theron may
have the solo record jolie has been a
model of consistency the maleficent
films the kung fu panda trilogy and mr
and mrs smith each did over 450 million
dollars across the globe with action
flicks like wanted and salt totaling 342
million and 290 million dollars
respectively although she's done nine
fewer flicks that we have box office
data for than charlize angelina's 31
movie library has outgrossed her
opponent bringing in a grand total of
6.4 billion dollars that makes for a per
movie average of 209 million the star
and now director regularly delivers hits
and can brag about having 11 films cross
the 100 million domestic line charlize
theron has only seven such movies
only but theron does have six movies
that broke the 300 million dollar mark
around the world and if you wanted to
pay really close attention and do math
you've already realized that angelina
jolie has eight such flicks here's some
easier calculus for y'all it's one to
nothing well that will be the score
after this round and it's going to be in
favor of angelina jolie a higher total
box office buck number on fewer movies
gets her the w but charlize theron did
more than enough to prove she's going to
be a major threat in this matchup it's
one to nothing now and the fireworks are
just getting underway
well well
what a glittering assemblage king stefan
round two tomato meter slash audience
score sure we love fast cars fist fights
and explosions but the biggest reason we
keep shelling out our lawn mowing money
to see these two bad ass ladies on the
big screen is because they always turn
out quality content reliability is key
and we can trust them to score big with
critics on the tomato meter and regular
folk on the audience score metric at
least we can trust them most of the time
hey look you make enough cinema you're
gonna have some milk duds so let's get
the misfires out of the way so we can
get back to properly celebrating this
duo who again i have to stress this
we'll not be teaming up today
good god who's that that's julia roberts
music no i'm just kidding we'll probably
start doing stunts like that next season
but for right now here are some movies
you probably wanted to forget
charlize theron starring in aeon flux
nine percent on the tomato meter okay
how about everyone's favorite
thanksgiving movie sweet november i have
no idea if turkey day is actually
involved in that film but it's only a 15
and a movie i drank multiple beers
during and still can't forget is the 19
that the huntsman winter's war earned
november
winter i have a theory that maybe
charlize should stick to the spring and
summer months angelina jolie also has
some real rotten skunks on her imdb but
some of these flicks were nevertheless
huge hits both of her tomb raider movies
are in the 20th percentile as is gone in
60 seconds then you also have the epic
misfire alexander at 16
and her low bar is set with antonio
banderas in original sin which meandered
its way to just 12 percent all right all
right enough cinema bashing let's gas up
the jalopy and head to freshtown charles
theron has a glowing report card that
features three movies in the 90 range
you want to guess them okay you do that
but i'll also tell you in the meantime
that tully is at 87 percent and long
shot and monster are both at a b minus
with 81 percent each all right enough
stalling her high bar is the twin 97
percent thanks to kubo in the two
strings and mad max angry avenue then
doing that thing it does it 93 is that
thing you do one of the ultra rare films
that is certified fresh and has an
exclamation point in the title only tom
hanks could pull off a miracle like that
while angelina jolie only has one movie
in the 90s really and it's 1998's gia
she does boast a bountiful fresh
filmography as kung fu panda 1 and 3 are
tied at 87 percent and wanted in beowulf
are tied at 71
weighing in at 70 even is sky captain in
the world of tomorrow
wow that's fresh
never seen it and i didn't forget about
you kung fu panda 2 you're doing just
fine at 81
the tides do turn slightly when we check
out the audience score joey pulls a
prequel obi-wan kenobi and seizes the
high ground notching 95 percent for
maleficent mistress of evil those who
wish me dead is at 85 percent and the
film for which she won an oscar girl
interrupted is at 84 percent charlize
theron answers the bell here as well and
crowd pleasers like f9 and the italian
job are at 82 and 80 percent
respectively it's a pretty great formula
drive a fast car you get a fresh movie
and monster for which she won her oscar
climbed all the way up to 81 percent
here and while angelina jolie wins the
overall audience score per film average
with a fresh 61 to charles is oh so
close to fresh 59 percent the slightly
bigger gap is found on the tomato meter
baron's per movie average is 52 percent
to joey's 47 percent but to be fair
ange's cyborg 2 doesn't have a tomato
meter score but i can't imagine it would
fall lower than 98 percent
also an accomplished director angelina
jolie did garner an 88 fresh tomato
meter score for 2017's first they killed
my father geez that was their opener
what'd they do next but her other three
efforts unbroken by the sea and in the
land of blood and honey all fell to
rotten territory it's a close call here
as both filmographies feature stunning
highs and a few hey we're starting out
in hollywood and need some cash flows
but in a nail biter i'm giving the edge
to the slightly better tomato meter
output of charlize theron in this round
round two belongs to furiosa and we got
us a tie ball game
round three iconic characters speaking
of furiosa that memorable turn by
charlize theron may be a factor in this
round which is all about the on-screen
portrayals that left an indelible mark
on us audiences action kick 3 dramatic
monologizing comedic retortery these two
a-listers can do it all but whose roles
left more of a lasting imprint on the
story of cinema
this is going to be a fun round angelina
jolie serves first and goes up 15 love
with her oscar-winning role opposite
winona ryder and girl interrupted joey
plays lisa and upon reflection said
quote i really genuinely thought i was
the only character who is sane in the
entire film
beauty and sanity may be in the eye of
the beholder but you hear a precocious
remark like that and you understand why
she's gone on to the career she has it's
inspiring to see how hard she pushes
herself initially she didn't want to
take on the role of video game legend
lara croft but couldn't pass up the
opportunity to train with the british
military for three months joey wanted to
see how far she could go and i would say
hundreds of millions of bucks later it
made it worthwhile
later she'd admit to craving more rules
that brought out elite physicality like
her character from wanted fox julie
previously had been doing more quiet
emotional roles and was ready to get
back into high octane action she also
raced into our hearts and gone in 60
seconds and as evelyn salt in the
straightforwardly title film salt but
let's not forget about those more
emotionally complex characters
christine's trauma at losing her child
in changeling would be a challenge for
any thespian but jolie is note perfect
in finding a heartbreaking balance
between outward composure and inner
turmoil charlize theron was already a
star when she took home oscar gold for
the role of eileen warnos a serial
killing prostitute in monster she gained
30 pounds for the role and that was just
the start of her physical transformation
and the challenges kept coming on she
would later quote usually you pick three
moments in a script and you wait for
those three days to come and really
stretch your acting muscles but in this
case every scene was that scene it's a
mesmerizing portrayal that it once
connects us to the human side of eileen
and alienates us from her demons and
while mavis from young adult hasn't
murdered anyone
yet that film is also a showcase for
therin to display a person who is a
professional success and a personal
disaster it's hilarious and
heartbreaking within every scene she'd
continue to mix it up with fun
over-the-top roles like cipher from the
fast and furious films and the pots and
pans wielding superhuman lorraine
wallace the namesake of atomic blonde i
may be partial to certain movies from
each competitor's robust resume but to
millions of kids around the world that's
not angelina jolie that's maleficent
embodying the evil soul of the classic
disney baddie with a dash of humanity
for which we feel a pinch of empathy is
no easy task yet joey pulls it off
tremendously but if it's truly iconic
you want then let's zoom into the future
and bring your gas card fury road may be
mad max cannon but that's furiosa's
movie theron was reportedly up late one
night contemplating the character when
she called director george miller and
said how about i just shave my head
miller remained quiet for repeat then
sighed and that passed for a green light
to get out the clippers the end product
is an iconic performance that stirs the
echoes of everyone from ellen ripley to
jean-claude van damme in cyborg
i you know i heard they made a sequel to
that and it's pretty good both of our
warriors in this matchup have plenty of
killer fight scenes that will fling into
the ring in the next round but if it
comes down to the one character that's
the most memorable it's gotta be furiosa
and i didn't even see the black and
white version of
the chrome version of pissed off
boulevard i look forward to many more
resonating roles from both joey and
theron but as of now the slight edge
goes to charles in this round from
monster to north country to the
dystopian future of mad max upset
cul-de-sac they're so funny to me and
probably no one else charlize there and
edges out angelina jolie in this round
and goes up two to one
slowly on the rocks
you pay attention
round four greatest hits if each of
these mega talented actresses were rock
bands they'd never have to write another
song again they'd be on their greatest
hits tour cranking out tune after tune
that you've heard on the radio for the
last 25 years and while angelina jolie
and charlize there and have plenty of
career or maybe their best songs still
ahead of them the legendary moments
they've created are worth revisiting
time and time again it'd be easy to say
that critically acclaimed flicks like
fury road or audience pleasers like
wanted are just one long iconic moment
and the host of this show has used that
line many times in past vids but the
standout scenes for me would be the
curved bullet sequence from wanted or
the first um meeting between furiosa and
max which ends up being one giant
glorious brawl far from damsels in
distress julie and theron proved they're
full on action movie stars in films like
these check out the acknowledgement of
tom hardy's max that it's furiosa who's
the better shot orrin wanted when it's
jolie rescuing james mcavoy during a
grocery store shootout evelyn salt shows
off her ability to macgyver weapons out
of thin air and that freeway chase scene
plays out magnificently as for mr and
mrs smith it's a super fun home wrecking
battle between that happy couple
even as they were possibly trying to end
each other's life and as for the movie
itself let's just say the chemistry
between angelina and brad pitt was
evident lesser known theron actioners
like the old guard and two days in the
valley still feature some insane fights
such as when charles and terry hatcher
get into a bit of a tiff
action chops are great and put plenty of
butts in seats to fill a theater but
these two stars can also stir us with
emotions just witness the gamut of
feelings theron's character jogs in
north country during the stay the hell
away from my husband's scene or the i am
not your mother heartbreak displayed by
jolie in changeling that one gets bonus
points because director clint eastwood
is famous for doing maybe two takes
before moving on to nail something that
intense and make it to josie wales's
liking right out of the gate is
remarkable theron counters well with her
terrifying turn in monster check out her
speech detailing regret and enjoy a
masterclass in acting
maybe could forgive me for
because i don't know
i don't know if i could forgive myself
for
we could jet to outer space with
charlize as well and even though i
enjoyed her cold approach in prometheus
i still can't fully get behind a film
that breaks the first rule of being an
astronaut no sleeping together in space
i've talked about this before come on
y'all you're trained for this take a
cold shower chug some orange tang and
save the bedroom shenanigans for when
you're not in zero gravity
you creeps
if you do like outlandish ridiculousness
i'd rather go with angelina jolie as
lara croft she not only punches a shark
in the face but her statue battling the
original tomb raider is wait did i just
say yeah she punches a shark in the face
that happened not since mahoney pulled a
gun on a great white and police academy
four has a shark been so intimidated
we've proven here that both angelina
jolie and choice theron can veer from
intense drama to crazy action without
missing a beat and if you say atomic
blonde then epic fight scene in the
kitchen living room hallway is great
then i would wholeheartedly agree with
you but i'd also point out that salt has
a pretty stunning stairway maneuver and
when theron was a sidekick in early
career actioners like reindeer games
joey was already making a lasting
impression as a true action star with
the tomb raider films again she punches
a shark in cradle of life go back and
watch it again
it's as close a call as we've seen today
but i'm giving the slight nod in this
round of greatest hits to angelina now
we're tied at two apiece which means the
tiebreaker will be determined by
the wild card round mystery movie ah one
of my favorite mental exercises that now
will determine the outcome of today's
match is a simple setup so you walk into
a theater you grab your snacks and now
you have a decision to make do you enter
theater one which is playing a new film
for which you have no context other than
realizing that angelina jolie is the
star or do you go into theater four
which has an unknown movie that you now
know stars charlize theron and you got
no other info theater two is playing
cyborg and theater three is featuring
cyborg two because come on we're a movie
theater we gotta make money it's not
gonna be an easy decision but we do know
that if it's an action film we're gonna
make the right choice regardless of
which theater we entered wear a croft
atomic blonde salt fast and furious hey
it could be that sequel we're going to
be entertained and even more impressive
is the willingness of both stars to get
their hands dirty when it comes to
preparing for the physicality of these
parts and their athletic prowess in
performing many of their own stunts
similarly if it's a high-profile award
contender we're in for one of the best
performances of the year jolie won an
oscar in the year 2000 and was nominated
again in 2009 for changeling when again
i can't stress this enough that ain't
her kid
she's also been nominated for three
golden globes since winning that award
for girl interrupted the noms came
courtesy of a mighty heart changeling
and the tourist
okay
who put the taurus in the prompter
really that movie was up for an award
wow did they see the movie
yikes theron took home oscar gold as the
monster wernos but was also nominated
for an academy award for her greatness
in north country in 2005 and bombshell
in 2019 young adult and tully also
earned her a bevy of award nominations
including the golden globes if we're
choosing a mystery flick just based on
the star versatility counts and this is
where charlize theron might seize a
slight lead her ability to disappear
into a role like playing megyn kelly and
bombshell or her fearlessness in playing
a monster or her willingness to put on
50 pounds to play tully is remarkable
additionally she's got great comedic
timing matching witch with seth rogen in
the rom-com long shot was no easy task
nor was it making us believe that she'd
actually fall in love with seth rogen
but i bought it
and if you want to point out that theron
was up for a razzy for her role in a
million ways to die in the west i'd say
well yeah it may not have been her fault
but still that's a risk going into an
unknown movie theater when something
like that could be torturing us for the
next 90 minutes but if it is in the
realm of comedy the smart money says
that the film will probably be more
along the lines of young adult where we
laugh at the obnoxiousness of the main
character yet can't help but empathize
too we see more of ourselves than we may
be wanted in her portrayal of mavis and
that produces a film that makes us laugh
and think as great as angelina jolie is
her comedic filmography can't live up to
her formidable action and drama resume
so while i'd be perfectly happy seeing
her in anything hey i even enjoyed life
or something like it i think the safer
bet is to walk into a theater for a
charlize theron vehicle i might be
hoping it's an action or where she kicks
tons of ass but i wouldn't be
disappointed with an intense drama or a
fun rom-com
and i know it's a risk because again a
million ways to die in the west wasn't
all that long ago so i would counter by
saying
the tourist i rest my case your honor
charlize theron wins the mystery movie
category and thus the match
buddy and i used to go thrifting all the
time remember that the 90s
oh my god beth we had this huge silly
t-shirt collection it was just like the
dumbest thing ever but i'll tell you
this angelina jolie has been one of my
favorite movie stars ever since what
film well it was one of the great
trailers in cinema history they counted
down from a minute teasing the audience
that in the time it took for us to get
our popcorn soda and seats nicolas cage
had already stolen our car
that was gone in 60 seconds and while
charlize may be my winner today i'm
still going to go as maleficent for
halloween
well i'll have horns anyway it's more of
a goat woodsy creature that i pull off
but i'm definitely ready to be one of
maui's minions and again it's just my
opinion we do it for fun and now it's
your turn to vote hit me up on social
media and let me know who you'd rather
see on the big screen i'm at mark ellis
live and if angelina jolie or charlize
theron are watching feel free to vote
yourselves and if it's not too much
trouble i'd love another atomic blonde
or a wanted movie please please or we
could just have angelina jolie pop into
the new furiosa movie that i think is
still happening okay you all work on
that and i'll just say thanks so much
for watching this episode of versus i'm
mark ellis and remember i am not your
mother
[Music]